[Música]
Hola bienvenidos esto es una semana en
el mundo el programa de France 24 en el
que los periodistas son los invitados y
Con quienes conversamos de una manera
más tranquila y distensionada sobre
algunos de los temas más destacados de
la semana en esta oportunidad hemos
invitado a alguien de la casa María
Clara calle usted la han visto en los
diferentes programas de France 24 está
con nosotros en el estudio es directora
de la sección de medio ambiente de
France 24 y a partir de la próxima
semana encargada de conducir el programa
El Debate María Clara cómo termina usted
la semana bienvenida Gracias Santiago
por esta invitación y bueno ya por lo
menos es viernes es viernes y todavía
con un poquito de energía Porque nos
falta la coronación que va a ser un
evento muy importante este fin de semana
y también está con nosotros aquí en el
estudio o nombre nos acompaña mejor
conectado desde la Ciudad de México
Mauricio Montes de Oca él es periodista
de ADN 40 como lo decía se conecta desde
la capital de la República Mexicana
Mauricio Bienvenido al programa gracias
por estar con nosotros y qué tal termina
usted su semana
qué tal Muchas gracias con mucho trabajo
con Muchísimas gracias por esta
invitación muchas gracias por
acompañarnos y Recuerden que ustedes
también hacen parte de este programa
dejando opiniones comentarios y
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
nos encuentran en @frans24 guión bajo
ese arroba santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta para que dejen los
comentarios numeral una semana en el
mundo f24 todo junto para que escriban a
través de las redes sociales entramos en
materia esta semana el 3 de mayo fue
conmemorado el día mundial de la
libertad de prensa la región de América
Latina no tiene un óptimo desempeño en
esta materia hay casos muy preocupantes
diferentes países en la región tienen
muchos problemas en términos de
persecución a periodistas amenazas
asesinatos también la difícil relación
con los diferentes gobiernos lo
señalamientos censura entre otros
aspectos comienzo por nuestro invitado
en México Mauricio preguntándole Pues
cómo ve usted la situación sobre todo en
México que es uno de los países que está
liderando Los listados Internacionales
en cuanto a ataques y persecución a los
periodistas Mauricio adelante
quisiera comenzar diciendo que de 2000 a
la fecha han sido asesinados 157
periodistas según la organización
artículo 19 y contrario a lo que podría
pensarse por la situación que hay el
país los principales agresores de estos
y estas periodistas no son los
integrantes de la delincuencia
organizada ni el narcotráfico sino los
actores gubernamentales Más allá de lo
que se pueda decir de el Gobierno
Federal y su relación con la prensa
estos ataques están muy concentrados a
nivel local a nivel municipal donde los
caciques locales son quienes agreden a
la prensa por otro lado habría que decir
también que México No no ha dejado
completamente descobijados a los
periodistas existe un mecanismo de
protección a periodistas y personas
defensoras de Derechos Humanos ha sido
efectivo en muchos casos lamentablemente
no tienen los recursos para proteger a
todas y todos aquellos periodistas que
quieren unirse ahí porque implica mucho
implica que haya protección implica que
haya botones de pánico que haya que
trasladar de un lugar a otro una ciudad
a otra a una persona amenazada y eso
cuesta dinero y hace falta este tipo de
recursos en México y María Clara aquí en
el estudio de France 24 su perspectiva
sobre este tema ustedes están Colombia
que es un país que también tiene serios
problemas en cuanto a la libertad de
expresión y al manejo de la información
y la y el desempeño de la labor
periodística Bueno al igual que nuestro
colega Santiago Yo también quiero
empezar con un dato y es del informe de
reporteros Sin fronteras que lanzó a
propósito del día de la libertad de
prensa y es el panorama que ha pasado
desde el 2013 hasta el 2021 y en ambos
años ha caído considerablemente los
países que se consideran en una buena
situación de defensa de los periodistas
pasando de un 14,4% de los países en el
2013 a tan solo un 6,7% en el último
reporte es decir cayó más de la mitad
vemos como a lo largo de los años la
libertad de expresión y la libertad de
prensa en concreto ha sido cada vez más
amenazada y en los países
latinoamericanos los que están
definitivamente en rojo son Cuba
Venezuela Nicaragua que era un poco de
esperar por el tipo de gobierno que
tienen pero adicional a este está
Honduras que también está dando un giro
a la izquierda y está persiguiendo cada
vez más a los reporteros que quieren
hacer un trabajo Imparcial
este tema lo tuvimos en el debate
también esta semana en el programa El
Debate y una de las personas que estaba
invitada Este programa nos comentaba que
había que mirar el espectro de la
situación un poco más allá de esas
dificultades de seguridad que también
había que hablar de la situación
económica de los medios de comunicación
porque eso también dificulta la
actividad periodística cuando los medios
tienen que cerrar y tienen que despedir
a la plantilla de periodistas reducir la
capacidad de producción de contenidos o
reducir por ejemplo esas misiones de
investigación todo eso también se ve
como uno de los puntos que afecta la
libertad de expresión finalmente se está
dejando de cubrir algo o de informar
sobre algo porque no hay recursos
económicos y era un punto importante
porque la situación económica de muchos
medios en América Latina también es
difícil es compleja muchos todavía no
logran recuperarse después de la
pandemia de Kobe 19 Mauricio María Clara
a mí lo que me llama la atención viendo
estas cifras que daba María Clara la
perspectiva que nos da Mauricio Es que
la situación poco ha mejorado y se han
profundizado los problemas y poco o nada
ve uno a los gobiernos por mejorar la
situación se trata de poner paños de
agua tibia pero no hay soluciones
concretas Mauricio
desde 2017 nos enfrentamos los medios no
solo en México y latinoamérica sino en
general a una un modelo de negocios que
no habíamos conocido que depende mucho
de los algoritmos que depende mucho de
empresas Grandes como Facebook depende
mucho de que Facebook te muestren y
estándar depende mucho de que Twitter
tenga un algoritmo que muestre o no las
noticias en lugar de las las
actualizaciones de Amigos o amigas
cercanas y ahora nos enfrentamos también
al la Inteligencia artificial no hay
muchos periodistas en temor de perder su
trabajo por esta Nueva Ola de de
máquinas que pueden hacer el trabajo de
algunos compañeros y compañeras pero en
general este asunto de la el
financiamiento al periodismo enfrenta
duros problemas en México enfrentadores
problemas en Centroamérica porque es
difícil informar a profundidad sin los
recursos adecuados y más cuando nos
enfrentamos a gigantes que no tienen
ningún tipo de regulación como Facebook
como Twitter como YouTube y ahí yo
quiero un comentario Santiago Lo
interrumpo y es además de lo que los
gobiernos pueden hacer para proteger a
los periodistas también hay un tema
sobre la mesa o quizás que no está tan
sobre la mesa y es la autocensura que al
igual que las presiones económicas de
los periodistas y de los medios es otro
gran tema que está limitando la libertad
de prensa claro es importante eso porque
también el entorno lleva que los
periodistas pues eviten revelar
información por temor a su vida a perder
su vida o ser atacados y hay otro punto
y lo está mencionando lo está poniendo
sobre la mesa Mauricio y me parece muy
importante la Inteligencia artificial
también está entrando a jugar ahí un
papel importante y la automatización
Andrés openheimer un periodista muy
reconocido en Estados Unidos entre la
comunidad latina habla de eso de los
puestos de trabajo que se van a perder y
uno de ellos pues puede ser los
periodistas ya vemos presentadores que
son hechos a través de la Inteligencia
artificial se ve usted en riesgo María
Clara cree que usted da como periodista
va a tener le va a tocar vivir de pronto
ese ese cierre de la actividad
periodística como la conocemos yo creo
que no necesariamente
en la actividad periodística Santiago
pero
sin duda una evolución que todos
Tendremos que dar no solo los
periodistas y al respecto recientemente
salió un informe relativo a la
Inteligencia artificial donde los mismos
desarrolladores tecnológicos reconocían
Cuáles eran los trabajos más vulnerables
a esto y dentro de ellos estamos los
periodistas y también los comunicadores
sin embargo yo creo que esto sucede como
todas las evoluciones tecnológicas que
hemos tenido cuando pasamos de la prensa
la radio luego la televisión luego la
internet y es que creímos que íbamos a
desaparecer y que nuestro formato iba a
desaparecer yo creo sin embargo que si
evolucionamos conforme a lo a lo que
haga la Inteligencia artificial y lo
hagamos con ética nuestros trabajos se
mantendrán Mauricio su opinión siente
usted que estamos como en una recta
final o Cómo podemos renovarnos para
garantizar libertad de expresión pero
entendiendo toda esta evolución que
tenemos en nuestro entorno
yo creo que los y las dueños dueñas de
los medios de comunicación si deben
tomar en cuenta que sustituir a personas
por máquinas pues No necesariamente va a
ser la la opción más óptima y está el
ejemplo clarísimo de las emergencias no
digamos siempre que hay una emergencia
en la gente acude a los periodistas
siempre que hay un sismo siempre que hay
una balacera siempre que hay una
erupción siempre que un huracán la gente
recurre a las noticias más que a las
redes sociales más que a tiktok más que
al entretenimiento en un minuto recurre
a los periodistas personas reales que
han estudiado que tienen un criterio
editorial y creo que ahí seguirá
recibiendo el valor de las y los colegas
para los siguientes años trascendiendo o
esperamos Espero que trascienda a la
Inteligencia artificial Yo quiero como
punto final sobre este tema antes de
pasar a los otros temas que tenemos de
la agenda es hablar de La otra cara de
la moneda y es Costa Rica un país que
está en uno de los mejores puestos en el
Continente incluso por encima de países
como Canadá o Estados Unidos en ranking
de libertad de prensa es el país que
saca la cara por la región está en la
categoría verde como una libertad de
prensa buena Yo me pregunto Cuáles son
esas características de ese país estuve
consultando las características de esta
libertad de prensa Y es que hay una
confianza de los ciudadanos en cuanto a
la información que se les entrega de una
confianza de los medios de comunicación
y hay un entendimiento entre el gobierno
las autoridades y los medios de
comunicación pese a las críticas y y los
lances que se pueden hacer de un lado a
otro Costa Rica tiene mucho para
enseñarnos María Clara no sé si conoce
el caso de este país y creo que también
puede enseñarnos en términos de
democracia Santiago y es que
independientemente de qué ideología esté
gobernando suele haber un respeto hacia
la opinión distinta y también implica
mucho el salario de los periodistas y el
dinero que puedan contar los medios en
este caso costarricenses y simplemente
otro dato para cerrar y darle la palabra
a Mauricio es Estados Unidos también ca
en el en el ranking mundial Entonces
digamos Estados Unidos va bajando y
Costa Rica cada vez le va mejor se
mantiene ahí Mauricio su opinión sobre
este descenso de Estados Unidos y pues
Costa Rica se mantiene se mantiene muy
bien posicionado Y es que el caso de
Estados Unidos Perdón ya ya le doy la
palabra Mauricio es el ejemplo más claro
de esa desprestigio del que estamos
siendo víctimas los medios de
comunicación por acusaciones de noticias
falsas Como por ejemplo lo hacía el
expresidente Donald Trump que acusaba
siempre sus ruedas de prensa señalaba
los medios de comunicación y nunca
Presenta una evidencia absolutamente
nada pero hay que daba el mensaje
enviado a la población
Yo creo que el caso de Estados Unidos
nos muestra que no solo la democracia es
muy frágil el régimen democrático se
puede destruir en cuestión de días en
cuestión de semanas ya nos lo demostró
alguna vez Brasil ya nos lo demostró
alguna vez Honduras ya nos lo demostró
Estados Unidos y Si de por sí el régimen
democrático estas instituciones esta
ideología es bastante frágil pues la
libertad de prensa es todavía más frágil
y yo creo que Estados Unidos con Donald
Trump a la cabeza dio una pedagogía
pública de lo mal que se pueden hacer
las cosas con respecto a la libertad de
prensa digamos ya la Corte
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos ha
dicho que los gobernantes tienen que
tener una tolerancia mucho más amplia a
la crítica que no están practicando pues
ni Daniel Ortega que no están
practicando ni el presidente López
Obrador que no practicó nunca el
presidente Donald Trump Y esa es una
pedagogía pública porque eso le enseña a
otros y a otras gobernantes y a otros y
otros ciudadanos a que los periodistas
podemos ser tratados de esta manera
pues se queda la reflexión de nuestros
invitados de este primer tema tema
destacado de esta semana lo decíamos el
3 de mayo fue celebrado el Día Mundial
de la libertad de prensa siempre es un
día para hacer balance sobre la
situación a nivel mundial nos quedamos
en la región en América Latina hay casos
mucho más complicados como China o Rusia
en el contexto de la Guerra de Ucrania
Pero pasamos la página de nuestra agenda
y vamos a hablar ahora del que puede ser
tal vez uno de los eventos más esperados
del año después de décadas de estar en
la fila de sucesión como príncipe ahora
el Rey Carlos III del Reino Unido pues
era finalmente Coronado en la abadía de
Westminster una o un enorme dispositivo
ha sido desplegado en la ciudad de
Londres en la capital británica para
esta ceremonia que va a reunir a lo más
alto de la sociedad británica lo más
alto de las casas reales europeas de
gobernantes invitados especiales en una
ceremonia que está repleta de simbolismo
llena de detalles ancestrales cada
movimiento está fríamente estudiado y
significa algo de este proceso tan
importante para la llegada del nuevo
jefe de estado del Reino del Reino Unido
y también de los países que hacen parte
de la mancomunidad Mauricio comenzó con
usted mucha expectativa allí en México
cómo cómo se ve desde este país hasta
Londres lo que se está viviendo en este
país europeo en donde hay muchísima
expectativa gente durmiendo en las
calles comprando souvenirs muchísima
expectativa en torno a la a la
coronación
a mí lo que me llama mucho la atención
de esta coronación de Carlos tercero es
que se reavivan algunos paralelismos con
latinoamérica mientras México le pide
Austria que se ha devuelto el penacho de
Moctezuma o que España pida disculpas
por la conquista hay países como
Sudáfrica que exigen la devolución del
diamante de la corona del que va hacia
el rey considerado el diamante más
grande del mundo y hay otros países como
antigua y barbuda que prometen celebrar
un referéndum para que este hombre
Carlos tercero deje de ser su jefe de
estado ahí me llama mucho la atención
insisto los paralelismos con la que
puede ser un considerada como una deuda
histórica con otros países de menores
recursos y también me llama mucho la
atención el hecho de que algunos países
la comunidad decidan que ya es hora de
que dejen de ser parte de este de este
régimen con Carlos en la cabeza
voy a incorporar en esta conversación a
María Molina ella es periodista y
corresponsal en Washington María
Bienvenida al programa se incorpora para
nuestro segundo tema pero comienzo
preguntándole cómo termina su semana y
la perspectiva que usted tiene de este
de esta coronación es tal vez el evento
del año por lo menos hasta ahora
bienvenido
para todos los televidentes pues sin
duda mucha expectativa frente a lo que
vaya a suceder mañana seis de mayo en
Inglaterra no tanto tiempo después
muchos británicos ni siquiera conocen
otro mundo que no sea ese mundo al que
conocieron con la reina que acaba de
fallecer Y pues ahora llega Carlos
tercero esta coronación muchísima
expectativa por parte de Estados Unidos
va a estar
en representación de la administración
biden y pues aunque aquí en Estados
Unidos el tema de la monarquía es un
poco lejano y no se entiende muy bien Sí
hay gente que le está poniendo atención
y pues esperando a ver qué sucede mañana
con toda la pompa y toda la ceremonia
que tiene que ver con una coronación de
un rey en Inglaterra algo que no hemos
visto en 70 años además es algo
histórico yo esta coronación no es una
coronación cualquiera hemos visto otros
reyes que han llegado al Trono pero no
ha tenido tanta repercusión en los
medios hace unos años el rey Guillermo
Alejandro de los Países Bajos llegaba al
Trono también Felipe vi en España pero
esta sin duda alguna creo que es la que
más
captura a nivel internacional y yo sí lo
considero un momento histórico creo que
vamos a estar presenciando una una
ceremonia muy ancestral tradicional como
lo decía allá en el simbolismo María
Clara su opinión sobre este tema en
efecto es llena de simbolismo Santiago
pero coincido con María y con Mauricio
en que es un poco más lejana de América
Latina de lo que puede ser para los
mismos británicos que como usted lo
decía ya están durmiendo en las calles
Para esperar y también quiero
profundizar en lo que estaba diciendo
Mauricio y es en esos símbolos del
colonialismo que persisten en la
coronación no Solo lo que mencionaba
Mauricio del diamante que tendrá la
corona del Rey Carlos que es de
Sudáfrica y que fue explotada en tiempos
de la colonia británica sobre este país
y sobre varios países africanos sino que
además hay otros elementos hay otros
diamantes en la corona que iba a tener
Camila la reina consorte y que tenía el
diamante de India el llamado
indoor y sin embargo Camila se rehusó a
utilizarla y no la tendrá puesta a pesar
de que Carlos sí debe ir con la corona
entonces empezamos a ver cómo también el
nuevo rey intenta adaptarse a estas
nuevas
a estas nuevas generaciones y también
por ejemplo tiene una postura más clara
en combatir el cambio climático una
postura que la Reina Isabel su madre no
solía tener entonces vemos también como
el Rey Carlos A pesar de que hace sin
duda parte de toda esta burocracia y
toda la institución de la monarquía está
intentando renovarla no tanto como se
esperaría con el príncipe William una
vez el Hacienda al Trono pero sí está
haciendo intentando acercar haciendo un
cambio desde este lado del Atlántico yo
lo veo con el respeto que merece pues
esta institución para el Reino Unido
pero yo lo veo como un espectáculo para
verlo desde este lado Y tratar de
entender esa cultura esa tradición
británica en torno a la casa real es
algo que no vemos en América Latina
entonces entonces pues desde esa forma
lo vemos pero para sin duda alguna para
los británicos pues es un proceso
histórico sumamente importante y y pues
cierra ya él todo ese capítulo de lo que
fue el reinado de Isabel II y pues Abre
este nuevo episodio creo que a ellos les
va a costar un poco Este cambio de Reik
creo que al mundo entero le ha costado
un poco el cambio de monarca o no María
en la ciudad de Washington Pese a que no
es nuestro Rey
no pero yo creo que los más famosos es
decir la monarquía británica sin duda es
una de las más reconocida en este lado
del océano y pues así no sepamos mucho
no se sepa mucho en Estados Unidos sobre
el príncipe William de lo que sí se
habla mucho es de toda la telenovela que
ha sucedido alrededor de el príncipe
Harry Megan las peleas familiares todos
los toda la telenovela que ha conllevado
esta pelea familiar en los últimos meses
ustedes saben que aquí el príncipe Harry
dio entrevista
con los medios más importantes de la
noche de televisión entonces a pesar de
que no se conozca mucho la tradición la
monarquía la en elegancia todo lo que
significa esta monarquía británica se
conoce el chisme Y se conoce ese chisme
de todo lo que sucedió y todo lo que
plasmó el príncipe Harry en su libro
recientemente de todas las peleas
familiares y lo poco que aceptaron a su
esposa Meghan María por qué nos genera
tanta fascinación esta casa británica
por encima de otras casas británicas
bueno es que también es muy
controvertida y da mucho de qué hablar
pero pero por qué nos fascina tanto la
casa de Windsor
bueno Diana Yo creo que es decir en mi
generación por lo menos crecimos con
Diana y crecimos con toda la historia de
Diana el desamor que sintió con su
esposo Carlos que ahora será Coronado
Rey en ese momento pues la señora que se
metió en el matrimonio que es la que
quien Ahora va a ser la reina Camila y
pues todo esta esta historia de la
princesa rechazada por la familia pero
que ella amaba al pueblo que el pueblo
la amaba creo que eso conquistó mucho al
mundo occidental y luego vinieron sus
hijos del príncipe Harry y el príncipe
William todo lo que pasó con ellos el
matrimonio con Kate middleton y
finalmente pues este último capítulo que
es el de la llegada de Megan una mujer
mezclada en raza entre americana y
blanca y pues que llegó allá a romper
con todos los los esquemas que había
dentro de la monarquía británica que
supuestamente se podía convertir en un
símbolo del pueblo y que al contrario se
convirtió en un símbolo de desunión
dentro de la familia británica y de
muchas
disputas y peleas en este momento dentro
de la monarquía británica es que entre
ellos dos entre los hermanos Ahorita hay
una muy mala relación y pues en esto
tiene mucho que ver Megan no estoy
diciendo que sea la mala de la película
pero digamos que su llegada que ocasionó
una ruptura esta historia sin duda
alguna el sábado tendrá este momento
Cumbre con esta coronación de Carlos
tercero en una ceremonia de casi tres
horas de duración y que tiene muchos
escenarios y bloques distintos
dependiendo del momento histórico que
quiere representar Mauricio su opinión
sobre sobre lo que vamos a ver en
Londres sobre esta expectativa
me llama la atención también que usted
vive en México recordemos México fue uno
de los pocos imperios que tuvo monarquía
en América Latina junto con Brasil sé
que es historia pasada y no tiene nada
que ver una cosa con la otra pero pero
simplemente me acordé del dato
quiero que tiene todo que ver es
precisamente por eso que nos genera una
fascinación chismosa en México el hecho
de que haya una reina en Inglaterra de
que haya bueno que haya habido el hecho
de que todavía hay un rey en España aquí
el último emperador fue fusilado en 1867
tenemos ya casi 200 años De no tener un
gobierno monárquico y nos resulta muy
ajeno pero a la vez eso ajeno Y eso
lejano nos resulta también una
fascinación por la fastuosidad por la
los protocolos es como un en México
conocer a niñas Bueno niñas jóvenes de
20 30 años que se llaman Dayana o Diana
o Lady di porque genera una fascinación
muy amplia en este país el hecho de la
muerte de la princesa Diana así que pues
sí hay mucha expectativa y todas las
televisiones del país o las más
importantes tienen allá ya un periodista
ya formado exactamente están todos los
turistas afuera del Palacio de
buckingham porque insisto esta distancia
nos provoca tienen una fascinación
chismosa por lo que sucede en Reino
Unido sí fascinación chismosa en México
gobernando los Habsburgo de Austria el
Imperio austrohúngaro y en Brasil los
braganza de Portugal es lo único que
tenemos aquí de vestigio monárquico
María Clara y yo quiero darle otro giro
a esa fascinación chismosa para utilizar
las palabras de Mauricio que me
encantaron y es Lady di la princesa
Diana sin embargo es una de las
protagonistas que cambia la historia y
que hoy está haciendo que Carlos III el
próximo rey de Reino Unido no sea tan
querido como su madre de la Reina Isabel
II Y eso también hay que tenerlo muy en
cuenta en la coronación Y es que no
tienen la misma aceptación por lo menos
dentro del pueblo británico como si lo
tenía la Reina Isabel sí es un momento
de quiebre para la corona para la casa
real de Windsor y bueno vamos a ver qué
rumbo va a tomar
esta casa real que es una de las casas
más emblemáticas en Europa dentro de las
familias reales vamos a ver qué giro
como usted lo decía María Clara el Rey
Carlos tercero si toma unas posiciones
un poco más abiertas la reina Siempre
evitó pronunciarse sobre cualquier tipo
de tema nunca quería tomar partido
absolutamente nada aquí por lo menos el
Rey Carlos toma partido en cuanto a la
lucha contra el cambio climático y La
Apuesta por por estar apoyando causas y
por estar difundiendo un discurso a
favor de la preservación del medio
ambiente pues última ronda para
conclusiones sobre este tema comienzo
entonces con María en la ciudad de
Washington de yo le pregunto va a ver la
coronación se va a despertar a las 5 de
la mañana María para ver la coronación
no por supuesto no me voy a levantar a
las cinco de la mañana pero apenas me
despierte el primer café le garantizo
que me lo tomo mirando los clips de lo
que haya salido de la coronación y
estaré muy pendiente de la forma
colovana como lo van a reflejar los
diferentes medios no hay que decir
también que esa fascinación que sienten
los adultos mayores en Inglaterra por la
monarquía no es similar dentro de los
jóvenes no y que poco a poco se ha ido
desvaneciendo esa magia que sienten los
jóvenes y hay que ver si el Rey Carlos
tercero logra mantener el imán con estos
jóvenes o si definitivamente se va
difuminando y se va desvaneciendo esta
figura a lo largo de su corona sí hay
que verlo a ver cómo van pasando los
años Mauricio su comentario
Yo también lo voy a ver pero también voy
a estar muy expectativa de lo que suceda
en Latinoamérica porque aunque parece
que no nos impacta lo que suceda allá Es
cierto que durante la última visita
oficial de la corona a Belice a Jamaica
Bahamas este viaje esta esta gira tuvo
protestas e incluso el Primer Ministro
de Jamaica dijo que el país ya se está
acercando a su lo que llamó su verdadera
visión de ser independientes yo creo que
en estos tres países podremos ver en los
próximos años quizás como ya dijo María
a la población le significa muy poco o a
la población más jóvenes significa muy
poco lo que suceda con la monarquía tal
vez veremos eh que ya finalmente alcance
su independencia ya lo dijo también la
primera ministra jacinda ander que el
país probablemente se convertirá en una
República con el tiempo pero no ahora
creo que eso es lo que deberíamos estar
muy pendientes en los próximos meses y
años sino y también hay manifestaciones
que se esperan para mañana el día de la
coronación manifestaciones de
republicanos en Londres y hay un gran
movimiento de Independencia en Escocia y
se esperan marchas también a lo largo de
la jornada María Clara su último
comentario por eso mi expectativa más
que en la coronación es que va a pasar
con la corona británica en los próximos
años porque hoy por hoy es una de las
coronas por no decir la más viva y la
más activa y la que tiene más presencia
Pero puede que esto se pierda mandato de
Carlos III y va a ver la coronación por
supuesto y en France 24 claro por
supuesto porque France 24 va a tener una
transmisión especial a partir de las 4
de la mañana hora de Bogotá quito y Lima
tendremos un equipo desplegado también
en Londres periodistas y colaboradores
en nuestro estudio en Bogotá que los
vamos a estar esperando Rosa Pérez más
déu y yo voy a estar aquí con ustedes a
partir de las 4 en Bogotá y seis de la
mañana de Buenos Aires para llevarles
todos los detalles de esta coronación
pasó ahora al segundo segmento del
programa y son nuestros comentarios dos
temas que tenemos también destacados de
la semana que simplemente hacemos una
ronda de comentario sobre la opinión que
tiene nuestros periodistas invitados y
les pedimos entonces pues simplemente
que nos den su punto de vista sobre
alguno de estos hechos yo comienzo
Entonces preguntándoles por esa crisis
en la frontera entre chile y Perú en
donde hemos visto represados a miles de
migrantes los problemas en la
coordinación entre los países la falta
de asistencia también la falta de
políticas claras está siendo muy
tortuoso estos procesos migratorios me
refiero a esta crisis entre estos dos
países en el sur pero claramente hay
escenarios también muy complicados en el
tapón del Darién en Colombia en la
frontera entre México y Estados Unidos
la frontera entre Guatemala y México
comienzo con Mauricio
a mí de todo esta crisis lo que me está
llamando más la atención Es que la
presidenta boluarte haya endurecido ya
su discurso en contra de las y los
migrantes y los esté acusando de estar
detrás de asaltos de robos de actos
delictivos en su territorio sin ofrecer
datos concretos como ya lo hemos visto
con Donald Trump como ya lo hemos visto
en gobiernos locales en México en Brasil
esta estigmatización hacia los migrantes
es una cosa que está permeando ahora en
Perú y creo que en el caso de la
frontera entre chile y Perú y presidente
Boris tiene la oportunidad de
representar verdaderamente a la
izquierda y tomar acciones humanitarias
A diferencia de la política migratoria
de México donde justamente hace unas
semanas acaban de morir 40 personas en
una prisión migratoria que se incendió
el director del Instituto Nacional de
Migración está vinculado a proceso está
judicializado por la fiscalía general de
la república Y aún así sigan supuesto y
aún así tiene que ir yendo a firmar para
permanecer en libertad creo que el
presidente Boris tiene la oportunidad
insisto de crear una política
humanitaria y no una política represiva
y de expulsión de migrantes opinión de
Mauricio Montes de Oca en México María
en la ciudad de Washington María Molina
su comentario es un reflejo de una
crisis regional es decir lo que está
pasando en esa frontera es solamente un
pedazo de una crisis mucho más amplia
que estamos viviendo en toda la región
yo he venido siguiendo muy de cerca todo
el tema de los migrantes aquí en Estados
Unidos la próxima semana finaliza el
título 42 que es una medida que se
implementó durante la pandemia para
poder expulsar migrantes pues aludiendo
razones de salud públicas Espera que el
11 de mayo está esta medida se caiga y
pues por eso va a haber una avalancha de
migrantes tratando de entrar a los
Estados Unidos mi conclusión sobre esta
crisis es que nadie quiere estar fuera
de su país todo el mundo quisiera estar
en su país pero desafortunadamente las
condiciones en los países y las
oportunidades no les están dando las las
oportunidades que estas personas que
quisieran y por eso tienen que arriesgar
sus vidas por eso tienen que cruzar Ríos
por eso tienen que pasar una situación
es tremendamente inhumanas y luego
encima de todo sufre una terrible
estigmatización
un poco a que nos humanicemos un poco
con aquellos migrantes que no son
números son personas que están pasando
por una situación tremendamente difícil
como sociedad nos falta muchísima
educación en torno al manejo de la
llegada de migrantes su su inserción en
nuestras sociedades y y como también
pueden ser un factor sumamente positivo
lo vemos en muchísimos países a lo largo
y ancho del planeta nos falta todavía
mucha educación con respecto a ese tema
y nos dejamos influenciar por los
discursos políticos y esto siempre
termina siendo permeado para aclarar su
comentario yo apunto algo que decía
María y es importante ver la situación
humana son 250 personas que cuando
decimos que están varados o están
atrapados es que ni chile los quiere de
vuelta ni Perú les permite acceder y por
ejemplo la mayoría de ellos son
venezolanos Venezuela enviará un avión
este domingo para recoger a varios de
sus conciudadanos y ellos no quieren
volver precisamente porque salieron de
su país de origen por las situaciones
económicas y políticas que atravesaban y
no quieren regresar entonces que los
retornen a Venezuela es empezar de Cero
y mientras tanto ellos están muriendo de
hambre muriendo de sed en un lugar como
el desierto de atacama que queda justo
en la frontera con Perú Entonces es una
situación que si uno intenta ponerse en
los zapatos de esas personas durante un
día es una situación caótica y que
ningún país los quiera y que encima los
gobiernos lo señalen de ser los
criminales y los causantes de la
violencia pues es algo Bastante delicado
me quedo con su frase ponernos en los
zapatos tener empatía con esta gente de
la situación que están viviendo nuestro
siguiente comentario por el que les voy
a consultar pues tiene que ver con
Gustavo Petro el presidente de Colombia
que estuvo por España vemos una política
exterior de Colombia muy activa visitas
del presidente a España los Estados
Unidos también en los próximos días la
vicepresidenta Francia Márquez va a
comenzar una gira por varios países de
África que ha llamado muchísimo la
atención en los medios de ese país María
comienzo con usted para hacer la ronda
la inversa su opinión que que dicen allí
en Colombia esta gira y tantos viajes
del presidente Petro ha sido criticada
Santiago sobre todo por lo que tiene que
ver con protocolo porque el presidente
Gustavo Petro no vistió frac como decía
el código de vestimenta de la casa real
española sino que fue Simplemente de
traje y corbata Y muchos dicen que es
una manera de hacer una presión o una
resistencia es decir yo no voy a vestir
lo mismo que las élites y también hay un
debate muy grande en torno a las
equivocaciones en su discurso del
presidente Petro porque confundió el
jefe de gobierno que es Pedro Sánchez
con el presidente o el líder de la
república Y recordemos que en España el
término República y republicano se
remonta a la guerra civil que dividía a
quienes defendía la monarquía y a
quienes defendían la República Entonces
es un es una palabra que tiene mucha
connotación política y Gustavo Petro
parece ignorarla o parece dejarla de
lado y referirse como el líder de la
república a Pedro Sánchez cuando no lo
es y cuando es algo que pone bastante
debate sí es el presidente de gobierno
la palabra República en España genera
muchísima controversia y debate María en
la ciudad de Washington su comentario
sobre esta gira bueno el presidente
Petro además estuvo recientemente aquí
en Washington e indiscutiblemente Hay
que decir el presidente Petro tiene una
gran relación en su gobierno con el
gobierno de los Estados Unidos y con el
gobierno de España no es cualquier cosa
que sea la única visita de estado que se
va a dar para un presidente en España la
máxima distinción que le pueda dar un
país a otro es una visita de estado y es
lo que acaba de suceder en España con el
presidente Petro en cuanto al protocolo
estoy de acuerdo con María Clara ha
generado muchos ruido ese esa romper el
protocolo como lo ha hecho el presidente
Pero hay una cosa que me preocupa mucho
más que el frac o no frac O que los
tenis de la ministra no que ese es otro
tema y es las llegadas tarde del
presidente Y es que el presidente no sé
si piensa que es que no importa pero de
verdad
los Estados Unidos y en España llegar
tarde se toma como un sinónimo de que a
la persona no le importa es una falta de
respeto y el presidente Petro llega
tarde con mucha facilidad aquí en
Estados Unidos dejó a los de la oea
esperando una hora y media los
congresistas esperando otra hora y media
en España también dejó en un evento
esperando una hora y 22 minutos y la
verdad es que eso nos deja muy mal como
colombianos es una falta de respeto que
el presidente no se ponga las pilas con
eso sí eso como un jefe de estado deja
muy mal parado al país con estos
protocolos Pues porque la puntualidad
con con el tiempo de la gente pues es
valioso pero hay que decir los
colombianos no somos reconocidos por ser
los más puntuales en la región Tampoco
tampoco hay que decirlo pero bueno
solamente por buscarle el lado de color
a este tema pero Sí incluso dentro de
Colombia ha generado problemas la
impuntualidad del presidente Mauricio su
comentario
pues parece que es una costumbre
latinoamericana en puntualidad por
desgracia a mí a mí Lo que más me
resultó interesante fue la respuesta de
la derecha en España el partido box de
sin salirse el parlamento a la llegada
de Petro y Santiago abascal Lo califica
como un ex terrorista pasando por alto
todo el proceso de pacificación que se
ha llevado a cabo en Colombia que bien o
mal es un proceso que verdaderamente
envidiamos en México un país que está
viviendo que vivió una una guerra de
sucia muy muy fuerte que no nunca tuvo
un proceso de
de justicia transicional y que vemos con
buenos ojos en Colombia estas
acusaciones que hace Santiago abascal
este líder derechista Ultra derechista
de vox de un ex terrorista son similares
a las que enfrenta la oposición en su
propio país y que estos argumentos pues
no fueron suficientes para que perdiera
la lección y que pasan por alto mucha
parte del proceso de pacificación de
Colombia que insisto vemos con muy
buenos ojos algunos en México Pues a
Mauricio María Clara y a María en la
ciudad de Washington aquí en el estudio
de Francis 24 en la Ciudad de México les
agradezco mucho por habernos acompañado
hoy en el programa por motivos de tiempo
me faltó preguntarles por los temas que
vienen y que van a tener bajo la lupa la
próxima semana se los quedó bebiendo
pero muchísimas gracias porque hoy es el
último programa de una semana en el
mundo de Santiago López aquí en Francia
24 que lastimosamente se nos va al aire
quiero darle la despedida Muchísimas
gracias María Clara y gracias a ustedes
por habernos acompañado y por haberme
acompañado en este último programa a
partir de la próxima semana los va a
estar acompañando Rosa Pérez más deu
aquí en este espacio ustedes pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios a través
de las redes sociales sigan con Franz 24
[Música]